let me make one thing clear right now
gambit are the best
cs go team in the world they've proved
that fact
over the course of 2021 with their
insane play
culminating with them annihilating na'vi
at the recent blast pro series spring
finals from an academy roster with
little expectations
to the number one team in the world
damn it must feel good to be gambit
[Music]
if youtube was a sentient voice thing
i'm picturing scarlett johansson from
her
would it just be confused all of the
time asking you to like the video and
subscribe to the channel constantly
would it be hitting that notification
bell making the dinging noise
because it knows no other existence i
have no idea
just a thought since the beginning of
the year hell
dating back into 2020 gambit has quietly
built one of the most consistent resumes
in all of counter-strike it's the type
of consistency that saw them
win intel extreme masters world
championship
back in february run through the
competition at blast springs showdown in
april
take a cool second place at both esl pro
league and dreamhack masters spring in
may
before straight up dominating the
competition that intel extreme summer in
june talk about a hell of a five months
and really if you take a look at that
second place finish at esl pro league
it happened against heroic's superstar
kadian
who pulled off one of the nastiest
clutches in
all of cs go history so really
not much to be mad at there then this
past weekend they capped
all of that off by running through every
single
team at the blast spring finals wiping
the floor with knobby and simple
to take home an easy 225 thousand
dollars but unable to find an angle just
yet there's his kills to booming in the
second onto bit
shiro connects to simple perfecto not
able to climb simple fall silent
and he tries to close that distance into
shiro opera versus oper
prodigy versus god he sees it at a
distance and nap and he's gonna take it
it is
camping as your blast premiere spring
finals grand
champs now the counter-strike landscape
that gambit has been dominating for the
better part of this
year is it's a weird one see as many of
you
already know when the pandemic started
back in march of 2020 it forced cs go
online
no more lands no more in-person trash
talking
you get the point this led to the
narrative that this online era of
counter-strike needed an
asterisk next to it because a lot of
people believed there was no definitive
way to prove
who the consensus number one best team
in the world was
it's something people talked vented and
argued about for pretty much an entire
year [ __ ] we had conversations all the
time about what the hell this online era
meant and to be fair for a while [ __ ]
was
weird the top five teams in the hltv
rankings were
constantly shifting for a minute it
seemed like bake was making a run for
the top spot
then it was heroic even g2 looked to be
making a comeback on top of that
both astralis and vitality were
struggling to retain their dominance
the point is there was no consistency it
never felt like there was a consensus
number one
best team in the world but the version
of gambit helmed by the veteran hobbit
that
just beat navi at the blast spring
finals have been
so consistently well-rounded that
they've effectively killed off this
online
era argument altogether because once
you've beaten top five teams multiple
times in a row which
gambit has that whole but it's online so
we don't actually know who's the best
can quite simply get there was even a
joke heading into the lower bracket
finals between knobby and
g2 that both these insanely talented
teams were
just ultimately playing for second place
that said even with gambit expected to
win it all
simple was still putting on a show goes
down to electronic that is an important
kill but there's only 20 seconds here
next over the headshot niko to follow
and this is looking
so crisp right now they had the call
that monitor from nexa
is everything they needed simple though
no what he's turned around
he's got three kills in the space of a
second and now it's a one on one
he's gonna go for the bomb plant he's
inside of the smoke and ammonic he's got
the pistol out he knows
but simples escaped out through the
smoke not dead yet
comes back for a little bit more this
can't happen he's on the bomb he's going
for the full defuse ice cold from
evidence
oh no he takes him down
anyway the undertaker unbelievable
now if you're a cs go head you probably
remember the major winning gambit
roster that hobbit was a part of back in
2017.
they pulled off an incredible comeback
against immortals at pgl krakow
the roster was stacked it was [ __ ]
great and honestly
a little unexpected
damn that have done it
but let's face it that era and that
roster which is enshrined in the history
of cs go has
long since ended adren had a few moments
with a vanguard and jamestime
zeus piled around with navi until he
retired in 2019
and even hobbit the stalwart leader of
this insanely talented 2021 roster
hit a few rough patches after leaving
gambit back in 2018
but then in somewhat of an unusual move
gambit
youngsters which is essentially gambit's
academy team
re-signed hobbit back in july of 2020
and formed a six-man roster
gambit have since trimmed its squad down
to a five stack but
at the time this was right at the height
of teams experimenting with that sixth
man position and although
gambit youngsters managed to crack
hltv's top
30 coming in at 28th that same month
they were still a relatively unproven
roster
now with a veteran leading them in fact
that youngsters team made such a good
impression
that they were promoted to gambit's
official roster
in october of 2020. what makes these
guys so impressive to watch is that they
don't play in the way that you expect
of course to have superstar potential in
axel and shiro but
primarily it's all about patience
working together as a team
forcing plays to happen on their terms
and sticking to the fundamentals of
counter strength
which is something that cs go
personality professor talked about on
the hltv confirmed podcast about a month
ago it's not like they're just running
around and shooting people in the head
or
they have like gimmick strategies or
like some
weird execute no one saw it's just like
playing
fundamental cs better than all of these
players that have been around for
so long and this new look gambit roster
with hobbit at the helm
was building momentum smack dab in the
middle of this
online era that we just talked about so
while they're getting the credit that
they deserve
now at the time when everyone was
bickering about what
when means what gambit's campaign for
number one team in the world was
underappreciated and it's easy to say
now based off of recent
performances that this was somehow
expected but
let's not get it twisted of course this
was
not expected you're talking about
pairing a
former major winner who'd been playing
in relative obscurity for the last few
years
with a bunch of young guns who weren't
really
on anyone's radar yet of course now it's
obvious that gambit should be called the
number one team in the world but
i'd struggle to believe anyone who said
that they saw this coming so i guess the
question
now is where do we go from here well
with sweden losing its [ __ ] mind over
hosting dota's ti 10
or i should say rather not hosting it
concerns have been raised about the
viability of the pgl
stockholm major scheduled to happen
later this year
in october if you missed that news yeah
valve put out a lengthy statement about
the swedish government
failing to recognize esports as anything
less than legitimate
which honestly has such a mid-2000s vibe
to it regardless whether or not it's in
sweden or another european
country amenable to all of the tourism
dollars that cs go will bring to the
table you just know that gambit are
going to put on a
show and i'm not one to make bold
predictions or
predictions at all really but it's hard
to imagine given the current landscape
of counter-strike and
the consistency with which gambit has
dominated the competition
that that performance will be anything
less
than outstanding but at the same time
just to bring it
full circle with this what the [ __ ] is
going
on with online cs go argument this young
gambit roster have never played at a
major land before
so the question is can they keep up this
consistency and
silence whatever doubters might remain
or are they going to fall victim to this
online asterisk theory
i honestly have no idea but
here's hoping they win big simple
s promoted to gambert
gamber who is gamber pozcast
he was on the postcast it's a little
long but i i almost had it